listen to this a major new discovery by
NASA could bring us closer to finding
life elsewhere in our solar system
scientists said yesterday that moons
orbiting Jupiter and Saturn could
provide a habitat for life
they have been studying data from the
Cassini spacecraft and the Hubble Space
Telescope Jan Crawford is inside the
Hubble telescope command center at the
Goddard Space Flight Center in Maryland
Jan good morning
well good morning Charlie so in this
room I mean this is where the engineers
and the scientists monitor the Hubble
telescope and a telescope and the
Cassini spacecraft are helping us learn
more about those oceans on the moons of
Jupiter and Saturn and these latest
discoveries could influence future
exploration in our search for life
beyond our planet this animation shows
NASA's Cassini spacecraft diving through
a plume of gas and ice spraying from
Saturn's moon Enceladus instruments
aboard the spacecraft detected a
significant amount of hydrogen NASA
announced its findings during an online
news conference but hydrogen is coming
from a hydrothermal vent on the sea
floor of Enceladus going out into space
through the plume here on earth hydrogen
from vents at the ocean floor serve as
food source for microbes these warm
oases if you will tend to harbor the
development of all sorts of life so NASA
is thinking that perhaps that's exactly
what's going on around these
hydrothermal vents at the floor of the
oceans at Enceladus we now know that
Enceladus has almost all of the
ingredients that you would need to
support life as we know it scientists
also believe Jupiter's moon Europa has a
sea of water beneath its frozen crust on
Thursday researchers also announced that
the Hubble telescope has again spotted
towering plumes of water erupting from
cracks in Europa's crust we're pushing
the frontiers we're looking in a way
that we've never thought possible before
for environments in our solar system
which may Harbor life to do that they
need new tools NASA will retire the
Cassini spacecraft later this year
nearly 20 years after it launched
[Music]
NASA engineers have already prototype
new technology to discover more about
these oceans including a rover that
could drill through ice and send samples
back to the surface we might find if we
go out there could be anything from
microbes which is much more likely than
anything else
maybe something that's more fully
developed now Thursday's discovery it's
just a first step NASA is set to launch
the Europa clipper which will go to
Jupiter in the early 2020s and it will
map its moon and possibly actually go
through those plumes to tell us more
about potential life on Europa Anthony
Wow so exciting what's happening Jan
thank you